we're inspired about what's going on
around the country people are helping
each other reaching out looking for ways
to make a difference following the
directions of the healthcare
professionals this is a proud moment at
the United States Senate and for the
country and we're going to win this
battle in the very near future Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell on the
passage of a two trillion dollar relief
package and state and local governments
small businesses and large companies
getting part of that deal for the large
companies loans would help them that as
we learn today that three million
Americans lost their jobs in the wake of
kovat 19 already this package is the
largest economic rescue in the history
of the United States of America here now
exclusively by phone tonight leader
Mitch McConnell leader leader McConnell
thank you very much for being here
tonight I know that you say that this
was a good moment the vote got 96
percent Senate support correct
absolutely and you know if you think
about it Martha we pivoted from
impeachment one of the most contentious
fights you can imagine to tossing this
rescue package 96 to nothing I was proud
of the Senate we came together in less
than a week which is a very challenging
thing to do in Congress with lots of
different types of people and different
points of view and we delivered it I'm
confident that I also pass it tomorrow
so in terms of the House Nancy Pelosi
basically said you know thank goodness
we got our arms around this thing
Republicans wanted it to be just a big
gift to corporations in America and we
wrestled with it and we made it
something that works for the American
worker and the middle class what do you
say to that
I wish Nancy would turn off all those
political talking points an awful lot of
Americans weren't for big companies so
we didn't want to exclude the employees
simply because of the size of their
employer she knows better than that and
that's just the kind of thing that she
routine
says I hope it comforts her members
because I certainly want them to take up
and pass this bill that not a single
Republican in the Senate opposed there's
already talked about what comes next
that this is just an emergency relief
bill at two trillion and as I said the
largest package ever to rescue the
American economy here's Nancy Pelosi
just one more thought from her about
what comes next we had a proposal on
pensions in the legislation that my
understanding was and I trust it is true
that the president supported but Senator
McConnell wouldn't do it but said we'll
do it in the next bill so we're ready
for that so what is the next role and
how many more phases of this do you
Caesar well we have a pension problem
but it's not related to the coronavirus
that's why it's not in the bill the
emergency bills that that we may have to
pass in future need to be related to the
subject and that was a problem here and
some of the elbowing was going on when
the speaker came back from California
and tried to get involved in the talks
on the Senate bill about suggesting a
number of things that were completely
unrelated to the corona crisis at
coronavirus crisis but more related to
the Democratic policy agenda so we're
not going to use these virus relief
bills as a way to pass a Democratic
policy proposals that's not what this
emergency is about so I'm about to talk
to economist Steven Moore who sometimes
advises the White House on on issues of
the economy he says that he's very
concerned about the hundred percent pay
that's in this bill for four months he
says he wants to get people back to work
and he's afraid that that's not going to
provide an incentive in some cases
people would get even more than a
hundred percent of their normal paycheck
in this plan what would you say to that
well we're all wrestling with that I
mean we have to listen to dr. Sauer you
just heard dr. Burks on
we can't get back to normal totally
until we defeat this virus and so our
healthcare professionals you know who
don't have a political label are the
people who can help us get out of this
health care just this pandemic which is
creating the economic problem and so it
is it is a tough call we all want to get
back to normal
most Americans are not going to come
down with this virus they're all
suffering from cabin fever iver because
they're stuck at home many of them
unable to get out and unable to get this
economy which was roaring back up again
are you Jeff concerns that we've over
over blown this in anyway when you look
at the clawback of some of the
assessments in these models and we and
you know the UK epidemiologist who's
advising the prime minister they're sort
of you know decimating his own estimates
of what would happen here what do you
think about that well I think we have to
follow the advice of the best
professionals we have in America and I
have total confidence in dr. pouchy and
dr. Burks they're the best we have to
give us advice about what to do in the
face of this pandemic and I think we
need to follow their advice all right so
I will see the other phases of this that
are coming are we gonna see three
trillion four trillion dollars in in
relief here over the course of these
other phases before I let you go senator
well I have to wait to see what happens
I sent the Senate home until April the
20th we can call everyone back if if
there's a need to act again but you know
the virus invades the Senate at the end
we had three members out who were in
quarantine as we voted last night and it
was Tom having finished the job for us
to follow the instructions we've been
giving the healthcare professionals have
been giving all other Americans all
right Senator McConnell thank you so
much sir good to have you here tonight
we look forward to speaking with you
more on all of this as it unfolds thank
you very much